[Music]
[Music]
dual staircases suck you really need
two different ways to ascend in the next
floor dueling staircases on the other
hand are totally badass
the job of a vampire is familiar is not
an easy one
it's very dangerous i mean they are
vampires after all how does this
documentary ever get made
i can see an investigative journalist
going undercover to solve a long line of
unexplained murders that leads them to a
family of ancient vampires i mean that's
the scoop of a lifetime but a tv
documentary makes
no sense are you just gonna gloss over
all the killing with a few awkward
stares at the camera
usually i would add a sin here for over
candling but i understand in this
situation it actually makes complete
sense
see i've matured and would now never
simply add a sin just because i can
having said that
here's a sin just because i
it is can i think it is the latch this
seems like a very fundamental design
flaw in a sleeping apparatus
upon further research i've discovered
that statistically vampires are more
likely to be killed by their own coffins
than steaks garlic and holy water
combined
the stupid ones at least who walks
around with a forking butter knife in
their pocket
you may be scared of bats i'm not i'm
scared of bat noses
nothing with a schnoz that looks like a
kkk hood can be trusted
full stop teleplay by jermaine clement
directed by taiko with td
some sin removals don't even need
explanations i'd like to read it in this
just a formality
it'll sound exactly the same if you read
it here than if you read it in there
laszlo would suck at tv since
wait that's not right people would say
please
don't pillage me highly doubtful
pillaging wasn't something done to
people it was done to places
nandor the relentless more like nandor
the relentless liar
please finish a whole victim before
moving on to a next one okay
would vampires call their victims
victims wouldn't they just call them
dinner oh dare you
bats i said vampire bats not cats
nandor is like a big turkey just
walking around trying to control
everything on the farm i don't think
that's how turkeys work
or farms for that matter
this camera person deserves a raise not
only do they stay in the direct line of
a murderous raging vampire they catch a
shot that perfectly illustrates the
interview conversation
you couldn't have scripted it any better
why don't we just write on them with
marco pen
name of the month yes day year
is the year really necessary surely a
half consumed body will be
way past its prime after 12 months
humans are made out of twinkies nadja
cover art of my sex tape we should get a
chariot
led by 12 black alligators
what about a van a van vampires converse
about crocs and vans for what
feels like forever yeah i know i really
had to shoehorn that last one in
okay i'll stop when the baron arrives we
shall feast on virgin blood
i always assume that blood would be
similar to whiskey or wine as in the
longer it's left to mature the better it
would taste
why am i making any assumptions about
what blood tastes like you ask
i will thank you to not ask and bid you
good day sir i said good day
sir vampire only laughing
that's familiarist energy vampires drain
people's energy merely by talking
to them can you laugh because you think
this isn't a real thing but have you
been on twitter lately
it's like a breeding ground for these
guys sunlight
aren't mandoor laszlo and nadja sleeping
right now because guillermo's screaming
loud enough to wake the
well you know this is terrible window
newspapering one of the reasons
newspapers work so well for this job is
the giant sheets can cover full window
panes so why are all these cut like used
individual articles people are gonna
think newspapers are terrible light
blockers and that industry could really
use a win right now
getting rid of carcasses i feel is a big
one
ah so this is where i've been going
wrong i've been disposing of bodies
under the cover of darkness all this
time
is something someone who disposed of
bodies would say while watching this
so we are under the stairs and this is
my bedroom
unwanted family member lives under the
stairs in a movie featuring magical
powers cliche
two things make a cliche right what hell
good friends
[Music]
there's still a few places to find
virgins
yes let's poke fun at the live-action
role players because they're clearly
unattractive nerds that must be virgins
just google matthew [ __ ] mercer i
dare you slarping stands for live-action
role-playing
well action has the a sound so
technically i think you mean
laughing do people really not understand
how this works
i'm not a killer i find people who are
easy
to kill i can use that logic too
i don't send tv shows i just find tv
shows that are easy to send
we moved here from europe about 200
years ago because there was a lot of
prejudice
against vampires at that time they moved
to america to
avoid prejudice
[Laughter]
classic premature exsanguination
he was delicious i've watched enough of
the office to never underestimate the
sheer volume of atrocities that
documentary crews are willing to
overlook but
how is this crew not immediately running
for their lives and contacting the
police
they're now accessories to murder i
would like some of that
a colorful dust that sparkles
glitter fish out of water stories are
fun until they're not
seems like we always end up with the
main character needing the most basic
explained to them
i mean literal cavemen were smashing
rocks to create glitter for their cave
paintings 40
000 years ago and we're expected to
believe nandor doesn't know what it is
just because he's from the
old country sleepy paper it's
crepe paper creepy paper thinking
something is funny just because you
repeatedly mispronounce a word
someone clearly took one of these cards
and didn't replace it in the correct
slot
honestly might be the worst sin in the
entire show you cannot play with that
i'm so sorry you just don't coin it work
in retail for any longer than a week and
you'll quickly discover the behavior
like this is sadly not exclusive to the
evil creatures of darkness and shadows
it's also prevalent among karens and
kins
i watch him in the night in secret
rookie mistake nadja an experienced
pervert knows that to avoid the pesky
reflective glare you have to turn the
flash off when taking pictures through a
window
so i've been told by other uh wow
sure is uh seasonably uh warm tonight
nacho turns into a bat while basically
still in this human's peripheral vision
yet somehow he isn't disturbed by the
woosh sound or the camera crew filming
it
leaving your shoes on why haven't i been
to this part of the house before it's so
lonely for 18 years wait
what how can naj have missed an entire
section of the house and why hasn't
anybody been down here for 80 years was
the door made of garlic crucifixes
colleen what are you doing in here this
is my bedroom
where did they think colin's bedroom was
how much of this mad house is left
unexplored
we're gonna have the ceremony in the
attic we can't the stair master's in
there
we're going to move the stairmaster no
one ever
moves a stair master it's just that
useless dust collector you bought on
sale and mentally with good intentions
but ended up storing in the spare room
until you find the
right space for it it's only when you
later move that you accepted you haven't
and will never use it
and so you sell it on to some other
sucker who ignores it stores it and
eventually resents it thus perpetuating
the sad
cycle of the unloved exercise steed
except there's no cycling
of course
my name is jeff she is totally about to
ww 1984 this dude isn't she
reminder ww1984 in someone is not okay
jeff means jeff i'm actually in a
relationship online but
we've yet to meet irl using irl makes
sense when you're typing but makes zero
sense as a spoken acronym
you're not saving any time it's still
just three syllables
do you remember that first time that we
made love and it was so passionate that
i accidentally cut off your head
hold up the depiction back here shows
gregor's head being removed from behind
with a sword
i'm not judging i just think this is a
very ambitious sexual position for a
couple's first venture into coitus
that or giving head means something
entirely different in the old country
but then i kept going squeezing until my
needs were met
this show for making me google how long
it stays
after the is finished
thank goodness this show's hornier than
a judd apatow movie in a rhino enclosure
and the rhinos are playing horny by
moose t
on french horns we three
not counting guillermo or june or you
or the camera crew right not gonna
mention them while you're going around
the room excluding people considering
there are about
three different coverage angles on this
scene and boom mic level audio that's
quite a full attic
oh it opens all by itself it's so cool
oh yes the wonders of a working latch
whoa that where they now article
covering the cast of the fantastic four
sequels got some serious ground to cover
with the silver surfer
[Music]
it's a documentary crew they're cameras
and he's just seeing them now
does the show think because we can't see
them that they're invisible to everyone
else in the room
i'm not an infant playing peekaboo show
well at least not that kind of peekaboo
[Music]
apparently guillermo didn't take a pass
at the attic when he was boarding
everything up from the sun you better
get back up there before their fearless
leader turns into barren crispy face
fond dusty pants
but when i awaken we will
rule this staten island
oh i've seen a sequel to this i couldn't
even tell that was pete davidson under
all that makeup
colleen robinson has trained them for
their energy
they have no nutritional value now but
why
they're still virgins and they still do
have blood right is there some vampire
lore i'm not aware of that exhaustion
spoils blood for the dead
this feels like a warm milk thing
because it's warm doesn't mean it's
spoiled
drink it be thankful for what you have
ten years of service
okay the internet's reaction next year
when cinemasins turns a decade old
somehow makes it into the episode
so if some of the crew just hung around
to film the baron's casket while he
sleeps
i suppose they might want to be there
just in case there's an opportunity to
let another murder happen
it's a nice routine you worked out i
hope you weren't planning on slaying me
i didn't choose the skux the scouts
chose me
guess who's coming to dinner what about
a van
a van down by the river
mania glass
[Music]
bath
it's getting kind of hard to believe
things are going to get better
material
[Music]
expecto patronage
oh you think darkness is your ally
you merely adopted the dark
i was born in it molded by it
i didn't see the light until i was
already a man but then it was nothing to
me but brighten